Something is wrong with the Chinese economy.
You can see it at job fairs. In rows
of empty, half-finished apartments.
And in the conspicuous absence
of Chinese tourists everywhere.
Take unemployment, for instance. In just
a few short years, the number of 16-24
year olds who can’t find work has more
than doubled, from about 10% in 2019 to
more than twenty this summer, before the
government simply stopped publishing data.
If you think the NASDAQ has
had a rough couple of years,
just have a look at the Chinese stock market,
which has lost about 40% of its value since 2021.
Or, how about real estate? Last
year, Chinese land sales reached
their lowest level this century.
One especially desperate developer
is enticing new homebuyers with $70,000
worth of – I kid you not – gold bars.
Consumption is down. Deflation has set in.
And for the first time in our lifetimes,
its population has begun to shrink.
The question is no longer when but whether
its economy will surpass America’s.
For the past two decades, most agreed
that the “West is declining” and the
“East is rising”. But, increasingly,
it feels as though the East has risen.
Are we witnessing Peak China?
Sponsored by Nebula, the exclusive home
to my Original series “China, Actually”.
The 2008 Financial Crisis should’ve
been disastrous for China.
The United States is its largest
trading partner. Thousands of
Chinese factories and millions of
workers rely on American consumers,
who suddenly found themselves out of work and
on the hook for mortgages they couldn’t afford.
Yet, by two-thousand nine, China
was back on track. It was, in fact,
the first major economy to recover. While
the U.S., Japan, Germany, and the rest of
the world contracted, China’s economy actually
grew – and by nearly double-digits, no less!
Ten years later, China was ground zero
for the COVID-19 pandemic. This time,
supply and demand were disrupted. Factory and
service workers had no ability to work from home.
But, once again, Beijing defied expectations.
It not only weathered the storm but was – as
before – the very first country to recover. Soon,
its exports soared to heights never-before-seen.
In short: no one has ever won by
betting against the Chinese economy.
So, how does China do it?
It’s simple: when in doubt, it builds.
Roads. Bridges. Skyscrapers.
Stadiums. Airports. Whatever this is.
It goes something like this:
First, Beijing makes borrowing
money laughably easy. It lowers
interest rates and drowns state-owned
enterprises with generous subsidies.
When money is free and losses socialized, you’d
have to be an idiot not to build highways,
bridges, and tunnels — even if they lead nowhere.
Much of this investment, obviously,
is unproductive. But it creates jobs and
raises the country’s GDP just the same!
Now, for a long time, this whirlwind
of construction actually made sense.
When Deng Xiaoping rose to power in the
1970s, China was poor, underdeveloped,
and in desperate need for even
the most basic infrastructure.
The simplest two-lane road or single-story
school was a massive improvement from nothing.
Just to catch up with the rich world, China
needed to build first and think later.
In 2009, Al Jazeera ran a story about Ordos,
China’s eerie “ghost city” in the desert. Here,
in this empty Potemkin Village, it proclaimed,
was irrefutable evidence of a housing bubble.
Today, Ordos is quiet but far from empty,
with about 2 million residents in total.
More recently, in 2017, CNN published this image
with the headline “China’s metro station in the
middle of nowhere”. Readers around the world
laughed at this hilarious white elephant.
Then, a mere two years later,
the station had transformed into this
and laughter was replaced with awe.
More often than not, critics were wrong and demand
eventually caught up with supply
as millions migrated to cities.
And yet, this can’t go on forever.
By definition, to maintain economic growth,
China has to keep investing more and more.
Meanwhile, the returns on that
construction are getting worse and worse.
This is China’s capital-to-output ratio –
essentially, how productive its investment.
Twenty years ago, it took $4 worth of construction
to generate a one-dollar return.
Today, it takes about twelve.
China is already a middle-income country
with rich country infrastructure.
With 25,000 miles of high-speed
rail and 3 million miles of highway,
it’s simply running out of things to build.
With nearly every obvious opportunity exhausted,
China is resorting to increasingly
questionable projects.
This, for example, is the
tallest bridge in the world.
At 1,800 feet above the ground
and measuring 2,300 feet long,
it’s an architectural and engineering marvel.
Impressive? Absolutely!
Economically-sound? Doubtful.
It’s located not in Shanghai,
Chongqing, or Hangzhou,
but in China’s equivalent of rural Mississippi.
Guizhou is the 4th poorest of the country’s
31 provinces and provincial-level cities.
But its per-capita GDP of $7,700 hasn’t
stopped it from building about 500 new
bridges in just two years – many of
which are among the world’s tallest.
Now, perhaps this $150 million bridge in the
mountains will be the next Ordos or metro station,
quote, “in the middle of nowhere”. Perhaps it will
spring to life and transform the local economy.
Given China’s track record, it would
be foolish to bet against any one
project. But it would also be foolish
to think this could go on indefinitely.
Think about it like this: Taking on
debt is perfectly normal. Sometimes
that debt takes years to generate
returns – also perfectly fine. But
when debt continues growing faster than
GDP, we know there’s a serious problem.
Previously, China would build, say, a new
airport – represented here by an increase in
debt and it might sit empty for a time while
demand for flights caught up with supply. We
might read articles in the meantime about this
wasteful “ghost airport”. But, after a few years,
we’d see a corresponding rise in GDP
– represented here. So far, so good.
Then, starting around 2009, we start
to see debt and GDP diverge. Here,
debt is still boosting GDP, but by a lot less.
We can see this more clearly by dividing the debt
line by the GDP line. The two grow at pretty much
the same rate – that is, sustainably – until
2009, when debt starts growing much faster. At
that point, China keeps building more highways
and airports, but demand never catches up.
This is the dilemma China
finds itself in today. The
old model – the only one it's
ever known – no longer works.
Now, there are only four ways to increase
GDP. Investment, which, as we’ve already seen,
isn’t a viable option. Government spending,
which is more-or-less a constant. And exports,
which the U.S. and other countries
are actively trying to reduce.
That leaves only one route forward:
consumption. In other words, China needs to
somehow convince people to spend more money.
And, needless to say, gentle persuasion is not
something the Party has been known to excel at.
As you can see, not only has it thus far failed to
do so, but it’s actually made negative progress.
Chinese consumers spend less than 40%
of their GDP. Americans, by contrast,
spend nearly 70%, Europeans, over 50%,
and the average global consumer, 55.
The main reason is real estate.
Until recently, buying property
was the tried-and-true investment
strategy for middle-class households.
Save prodigiously, pool together money
from family, and every urban couple could
buy an apartment – or more often, two
or three – and live the Chinese Dream.
Most of these homes were sold before
construction had even finished – allowing
developers to immediately take these
down payments and start building more.
All it took, therefore, was one set of buyers to
stop making payments last year and
the whole system came crashing down.
For two decades, the country was taught that
property was the only safe investment. Then,
property stopped being a safe investment.
No wonder Chinese consumers are worried.
Now the problem is one of confidence.
It’s simple, really: When
you receive your paycheck,
how do you decide whether to save or spend it?
Generally speaking, you spend
it when you’re confident you’ll
keep receiving more and you’ll
save it if you aren’t so sure.
Well, Chinese consumers aren’t so sure.
In the last 4 years, they’ve absolutely
stuffed their bank accounts to the brim
with money and cut back on big, flashy
purchases like cars, TVs, and furniture.
They’re still traveling, but mostly domestically.
They’re still spending, but mostly on sales.
So, naturally, in order to incentivize
purchases, companies are lowering their prices.
These lower prices – and therefore profits
– are leading to layoffs and reduced wages.
Finally, these layoffs are making
consumers even less confident,
and as a result, less likely to go
shopping – completing the cycle.
Until and unless China interrupts
this positive feedback loop,
it will be forced to accept lower economic growth.
Now, alright, let’s put things in perspective.
Between 1979 and today, China saw what the
World Bank calls “the fastest sustained
expansion by a major economy in history”.
Those four decades were anomalous. They weren’t
sustainable. And they were
simply never going to last.
Its economy is still growing – albeit much
more slowly. Its middle class is still 700
million people strong. And its military
is still the world’s second-largest.
China is not going away. To argue
otherwise is to overcorrect from
the prior era of optimism — to make the
same mistake, in the opposite direction.
But the lightning-fast growth
that led to speculation about
an “Asian Century” – is going away.
And there’s very little it can do.
At the very heart of this
slowdown are demographics.
As long as the population was growing,
China could build almost aimlessly,
confident there would be a steady supply of bodies
to fill every “ghost city”, airport, and highway.
But, as of last year, China is now actively
shrinking. Its birth rate has already dropped
to the lowest level in the world – just
1.09 children per woman. And by 2030,
the labor force is expected to
decrease by about 1% every year.
One of the great mysteries behind
this demographic collapse is why
China kept the One-Child Policy
around for so long – until 2016.
Surely, its leaders had to have known
the population would begin to shrink. So,
why then were families still
prohibited from having more children?
Find out the answer to this
question in the latest, 20-minute,
7th installment of my Nebula Original series
“China, Actually”. Here’s a quick preview:
the single most effective national policy in
history in the fight against climate change
Anyone could see that it
just wasn’t going to work.
there’s much more to this story
“China, Actually” is and will always be exclusive
to Nebula – the creator-owned streaming platform.
Nebula is also home to Originals like
RealLifeLore’s deep dives into recent wars,
Modern Conflicts, Wendover Productions’ “Logistics
of X” series about how things like coal mining and
search and rescue work, and Real Engineering’s
beautifully-rendered “Battle of Britain”.
With a Nebula subscription, you also
get access to Nebula Plus bonus content,
Nebula First early releases, and Nebula Classes,
where you can go behind the scenes
with some of your favorite creators.
You can get all that for 50% off by signing up
for an annual plan with the link on screen now
or in the description. At just $2.50 a month,
that’s a pretty fantastic deal if you ask me.